ON SPECIFIC FORMULA BECAUSE SHE
HAS A RARE GENETIC DISEASE THAT
REQUIRES HER TO BE FED BY TUBE
AND WE'VE BEEN FOLLOWING HER
THROUGH THIS CRISIS, YOU MAY
HAVE SEEN HER SPEAK WITH ADRIAN
THROUGH THE SPECIAL REPORT AND
ANNA, I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME.
GOSH, MY HEART GOES OUT TO YOU.
I KNOW BROOKLYN WAS IN THE
HOSPITAL RECENTLY, HAD TO BE PUT
ON LIFE SUPPORT AND YOU SHARED
SOME PHOTOS WITH US THAT ARE
DIFFICULT TO LOOK AT BUT WE'RE
SHARING THEM BECAUSE YOU WANTED
TO SHOW THEM TO PEOPLE SO YOU
CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS IS
LIKE.
HOW CONCERNED ARE YOU SHE COULD
END UP BACK IN THE HOSPITAL IF
THIS SHORTAGE OF WHAT SHE NEEDS
TO LIVE CONTINUES?
>> HONESTLY, I'M EXTREMELY
TERRIFIED BECAUSE THE HOSPITAL
IS A LAST PLACE AN
IMMUNOCOMPROMISED CHILD NEEDS TO
BE.
>> SO WHAT IS HER SITUATION NOW?
>> SO MY DAUGHTER HAS A RARE
GENETIC DISEASE CALLED SPINAL
MUSCULAR ATROPHY TYPE 1 AND SHE
CAN ONLY TOLERATE ONE FORMULA,
IT'S AN AMINO ACID-BASED FORMULA
AND BECAUSE OF HER DISEASE, HER
BODY CANNOT BREAK DOWN ANIMAL
FATS AND PROTEINS SO SHE HAS TO
HAVE THIS AMINO ACID-BASED
FORMULA.
RIGHT NOW I'M HAVING TO SCOUR
THE INTERNET TO GET THIS FORMULA
FOR HER SO WE DO NOT END UP BACK
IN THE HOSPITAL.
IF I'M UNABLE TO KEEP HER
FORMULA IN STOCK, AND SHE GOES
THROUGH ONE CAN EVERY TWO DAYS
SO IF I'M UNABLE TO KEEP, YOU
KNOW, HER NUTRITION GOING, SHE'S
GOING TO HAVE TO BE HOSPITALIZED
FOR TPN IV NUTRITION.
>> SO THIS MUST CONSUME YOUR
LIFE EVERYDAY, WHAT IS IT LIKE
EVERYDAY TRYING TO GO ONLINE TO
FIND FORMULA SO YOU CAN GET HER
ANOTHER COUPLE OF DAYS?
>> IT IS SO EXHAUSTING.
AND NOT TO MENTION, NO MATTER
WHERE I LOOK, THE FORMULA IS
PRICE-GOUGED SO BADLY.
JUST TO PUT IT INTO PERSPECTIVE,
ON THE MANUFACTURER'S WEBSITE, A
CASE OF FOUR CANS, WHICH IS AN
EIGHT DAY SUPPLY FOR MY DAUGHTER
NORMALLY COSTS $168.
RIGHT NOW, I'VE BEEN HAVING TO
PAY UPWARDS OF $300 EVERY EIGHT
DAYS AND HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS
HELP AND, YOU KNOW, HAVE HAD
SOME HELP FROM OUTSIDE SOURCES
BUT IT'S RIDICULOUS THAT IT'S
COSTING THAT MUCH.
ESPECIALLY FOR MY DAUGHTER WHO
HAS A PRESCRIPTION FOR THIS
FORMULA AND WE'RE UNABLE TO
OBTAIN THE PRESCRIPTION.
>> AND, BECAUSE OF WHERE YOU'RE
SOURCING IT FROM?
>> SO NORMALLY, SHE WOULD GET
HER FORMULA SHIPPED THROUGH HER
DNE COMPANY AND THE DME COMPANY
IS UNABLE TO GET THE FORMULA IN
STOCK.
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO SEND
HER FORMULA PRESCRIPTION IN
THREE MONTHS NOW WHICH HAS LEFT
US SCRAMBLING AND LOOKING, YOU
KNOW, FRANTICLY FOR THE FORMULA
JUST TO KEEP HER HOME AND IF I
FIND IT, YOU KNOW, LIKE FOR
INSTANCE, A FEW DAYS AGO I FOUND
A SHIPMENT AT A WALLGREENS
LOCAL, MEDICAID DENIED COVERAGE
OF THE FORMULA AT THE WALGREENS
BECAUSE IT'S TECHNICALLY NOT A
DRUG AND IT'S OVER THE COUNTER
SO THEY WOULDN'T COVER IT UNLESS
IT'S COMING FROM THE DME COMPANY
LEAVING US TO PAY OUT OF POCKET
FOR 13 CANS WHICH WAS, YOU KNOW,
$600.
SO THANKFULLY WE HAD --
>> AND OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND NOT SUSTAINABLE
AND I HOPE THAT GETS
RESPECTIFIED, GOING BACK WHEN
THIS IS RESOLVED.
OBVIOUSLY -- BUT THE FDA
COMMISSIONER SAYS IT'S GOING TO
BE A FEW WEEKS BUT OBVIOUSLY
IT'S ALREADY BEEN THREE MONTHS,
NOW IT'S THIS URGENT THING AND
SAYING IT'S GOING TO BE A FEW
WEEKS IF IT IS MOVES URGENTLY.
IS THIS GOOD ENOUGH?
>> NO, THE SECOND THE BABIES
WERE WITHOUT FORMULA SHOULD HAVE
BEEN A NATIONAL CRISIS, BECAUSE
TWO WEEKS, THREE WEEKS, TO THEM
IS NOTHING BUT TO US, A FAMILY
LIKE ME WHO IS ALREADY
MEDICALLY, HAVE A MEDICALLY
COMPLEX CHILD AND I'M ALREADY
FINANCIALLY STRAINED, THAT'S,
YOU KNOW, A COUPLE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR FORMULA THAT I CAN'T
AFFORD RIGHT NOW, DURING A
PANDEMIC.
>> ANGELA, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR EXPLAINING ALL OF THIS.
I HOPE PEOPLE HEAR YOU AND HEAR,
YOU KNOW, AS YOU USE THE WORD
FRANTIC, THAT YOU'RE FRANTICLY
SEARCHING AND WHAT YOU'RE GOING
THROUGH FINANCIALLY, IT IS
UNACCEPTABLE A